الآن يصف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
هذا الاقتباس بأنه
عملية عسكرية خاصة لحماية دون باس ، فمن
الواضح أنه أكبر من ذلك الآن ظهر بشكل
مفاجئ على التلفزيون الحكومي
داعياً إلى نزع السلاح من
أوكرانيا وألقى باللوم على الحكومة في كييف
في إراقة الدماء لكنه قال إن القوات الروسية
لا يخططون لاحتلال
من يحاول التدخل معنا ،
بل والأكثر من ذلك لخلق تهديدات لبلدنا ،
يجب أن يعرف شعبنا أن
استجابة روسيا ستكون فورية
وستقودك إلى
عواقب لم تشهدها من قبل في
تاريخك الآن رئيس أوكرانيا فلاديمير
zielinski ذهب مرة أخرى إلى الفيسبوك
ليخاطب الأمة ويقول إنه يفرض
الأحكام العرفية ، لكنه حث الدولة على عدم
الذعر
اليوم ، يجب على كل واحد منكم أن يظل هادئًا
في المنزل إذا كان
بإمكانك العمل ، فالجيش يعمل في
قطاع الدفاع والأمن بأكمله
لا يوجد ذعر نحن أقوياء ونحن مستعدون لكل
شيء سنفوز به على الجميع
لأننا  هي أوكرانيا
وجمهورية لاجونسك الشعبية ودونيتسك
بحاجة إلى مساعدتنا ، لقد طلبوا
مساعدتنا في هذا الصدد
من الميثاق السابع
من ميثاق الأمم المتحدة
للجمعية الإقليمية
بشأن اتفاقية الصداقة والمساعدة
مع شعب نيتشه
وشعب لوغانسك
تم اتخاذ قرار بشأن
عملية عسكرية خاصة
هدفها هو الدفاع عن الأشخاص الذين
تحملهم ثمانية أشخاص ثمانية أعوام تعرضوا لها بإذلال رهيب وأي شخص يحاول أن يتدخل ليكون
تهديدًا لبلدنا يجب أن يعرف
أنه هناك  هل سيكون رد روسيا
سريعًا وسيعطيك مثل هذه
العواقب
التي لن تواجهها أبدًا مرة أخرى ، وواجهت
مرة أخرى
تاريخك ، قال الرئيس بايدن إن العالم
سيحاسب روسيا على أفعالها.
فكر في فرض ضوابط على الصادرات
لمزيد من العقوبات على النفط والغاز الروسي
والمزيد من العزلة
للنظام المالي الروسي للولايات المتحدة
قطعت روسيا بالفعل عن التمويل الغربي
بفرض عقوبات على بنكين كبيرين
وديونها السيادية والشركة التي تقف وراء
nordstream 2 أن خط أنابيب الغاز
بين روسيا وألمانيا قد
أوقف اعتمادها في خطوة مثيرة
لأن الاتحاد الأوروبي يعتمد على روسيا
لأكثر من ثلث  غازها الطبيعي
يضرب روسيا حيث يضر جون
بفرض عقوبات على طاقتها التي يمكن أن
تحمل تكلفة للغرب ، فهي من أكبر
منتجي النفط والغاز الطبيعي العالم
مدمن على الصادرات الروسية في الاتحاد الأوروبي
مما يعني ارتفاع تكاليف التدفئة المنزلية
والكهرباء في الولايات المتحدة  هذا يعني
ارتفاع الأسعار في المضخة بالفعل 3.54
للغالون وارتفاع أسعار الطاقة ،
وخاصة الغاز ، وهو محرك رئيسي
للتضخم المرتفع بالفعل ، مما أدى بالفعل
إلى خسائر سياسية ، مما وضع قادة الغرب
هنا في موقف صعب تعهد الرئيس
بايدن هذا الأسبوع باستخدام كل
أداة لتخفيف حدة هذه الأسعار.  أسعار الغاز جون ولكن
هذه الأدوات محدودة ويمكن
للولايات المتحدة الضغط على المنتجين لفتح
حنفياتهم وإطلاق النفط من المخزن الاستراتيجي
ربما تقدم ckpiles عطلة ضريبية على الغاز في روسيا
بالمناسبة تدفع بالفعل سعرًا ماليًا كبيرًا ، حيث
تحطمت الأسهم الروسية بأكثر من
40 في المائة بين عشية وضحاها
ووصل الروبل إلى مستوى قياسي مقابل الدولار ،
وسأطلب منك ذلك
لأنه قبل بضع دقائق  عندما تحققت من
أنه كان أقل من نصف قيمته ، ما
نوع التأثير الذي يحدثه ذلك على
الاقتصاد الروسي بالنسبة لسوق يخسر
نصف قيمته ،
إنه أمر مدمر ويظهر لك أن
مقامرة بوتين هنا تأتي مع
تكلفة لبلده مثل  حسنًا ، البنك المركزي ،
نتوقع
أن يتدخل البنك المركزي والبنك المركزي الروسي
بتدخل كبير لمحاولة دعم
تلك العملة واقتصادها